so I wanted to do a little Twitter Q&A
with you guys so I tweeted out if you
have any questions for me pretty
brilliant right that's how it works and
a bunch of you guys responded so we
picked a couple and I think we're due a
few of these but here let's get to a
couple questions that you had for me on
the twitter merecido 7 asked how many
now that the bandwagon has joined us
Americans you think would punch Dick
Cheney in the face upon meeting him that
is a good question um I think in the
circles that I travel in uh and in the
TYT circles and in most democratic
circles and progressive circles a lot of
punches there would be a lot of punches
um I think the Republican circles not so
many punches I think if I was trying to
answer this seriously I do think there's
a small percentage of people that if
they just saw him would want to attack
him and that's why I guess these guys
have Secret Service and all that but Jen
if I saw the guy I wouldn't punch him I
would love to talk to him I don't agree
obviously a lot of things and you know
he's still preaching now about what we
should be doing in Iraq when he was the
architect of an utter disaster and now
we're seeing the fruits of it so I would
still want to talk to him and really try
to get some more truth out of him really
talk about Halliburton and how that all
affects his decisions and that kind of
thing so I wouldn't want to punch him
but I guess I'm more of a lover than a
fighter all right Melissa amol said if
you weren't in media what career path
you think you'd pursue instead this
one's actually kind of interesting so I
studied political science in college so
I guess I'm doing something kind of
right here and I remember very vividly
being in one of my classes junior year
and just the professor just kept talking
about how the government just doesn't
work like it's supposed to now this was
probably in about nineteen ninety-seven
so our government was actually pretty
functional back then compared to the
insane gridlock that we have now and he
was just talking about how the branches
are always fighting we don't get
legislation passed that's good for the
people talking about money in politics
and how everything's being bought and
again this is at this now this is 15 16
17 years ago so I wanted to be a
politician is the answer to your
question I was studying
politics and I wanted to be a politician
I remember being in the class and they
allow this thing is so warped this thing
is so warped like how could I be a part
of it you know and then I started
thinking maybe I was going to do a
little stand up or something like that
and then I did stand-up comedy literally
the last thing that I was going to do in
college I was taking a public speaking
class and I taken all my finals I was
going home as a graduate like two days
later and i did a public speaking class
they want and it was about summing up
your college experience and i did a
little stand up and i sat down like Bill
Cosby and my favorite special himself
from I think 1983 and I did a little
summation of what I thought College was
like and half the class laughed and half
the class thought i was nuts and I was
like all right I guess that makes me a
comedian and I went to an open mic in
New York a week later and Here I am now
so there you go next up Eric Wallace 117
would you ever run for public office so
I was that sort of goes back to what I
was just talking about I I don't think
so i think for me my place is talking
about it i think you get to be a lot
more honest as someone on the outside
and hopefully can influence some things
and i try to be as honest as I can and
talk about these things in a fun way
because when you watch all these shows
everybody's yelling everyone's partisan
they're bought and sold I have nobody
telling me what I can say and it's a
beautiful thing and that's why the
internet is the future and I think we're
forcing TV maybe to be a little more
honest but running for public office I
don't think I could do it like i think i
think i would love the process some of
the process of it and getting in there
and really negotiating things and
talking about the issues and talking to
the people but the endless fundraisers
even right now as i do this president
Obama has three fundraisers in these two
days I think he's at a fundraiser right
now in Dallas while I'm doing this so
that part of it I just I wouldn't want
to do and have to sit at all those
tables and listen to all the people who
are just there because they have money I
just simply don't think I could do it so
I think my role is to to be on the
outside and talk about it and
and hopefully for me it's it's uh it's
cathartic for me uh and I hope you guys
did what I'm doing so so that kind of
works for everybody next up just smoke
think I said that right says uh do you
think as long as we give credit to
organizations like the Catholic Church
for their quote charities we must give
Hamas the same because they both claim
good work for people yet they both do a
great deal harm more than good I would
rather have neither uh you know this is
this is an interesting topic because you
know we talked about how religion uh
especially the religious right in
America has dictated so much public
policy um that's far different from
Hamas which is a terrorist organization
which is actually holding their own
people hostage and also firing rockets
at another country um so I don't think
the Catholic Church is doing that that
being said they've done some odd things
related to women's reproductive rights
and gay rights and all that uh whether
churches or religious organizations
should have tax exemption is a whole
other thing I don't really think so uh
they do do some good work of course but
I don't think we can really put the
Catholic Church and and Hamas on the
same level garden gnome 88 was to know
what did do your parents do for a living
do you think it's shaped your
aspirations uh so my dad works in sales
in the garment Center and my mom was a
stay-at-home mom for most of my growing
up and then was a nursery school teacher
for many years after that she just
retired and my dad still works do I
think it's shaped me um you know I grew
up I grew up middle class in in a very
decent area I thought we lived on the
wrong side of the tracks of the town we
grew up on but you know we we were okay
and I think that I think growing up sort
of okay uh let let itself to comedy uh
because ever because most people think
they're growing up okay even when you're
not growing up okay you think you're
grown up okay and there's something
funny about that there I always thought
there was just something a little off in
the world I don't know that it directly
had anything to do with my parents jobs
which is growing up in the suburbs
there's something funny going on there
there is something weird and funny going
on in the suburbs and yeah I I think it
had something to do with the path that
I'm on
right now and this is still even though
I've been doing you know I started
stand-up in 98 the path you know 16
years later I still feel like I'm at the
beginning of it so it's kinda cool
alright so that is our Twitter QA I
think I'm gonna do this more often so
please do play along follow me at Rubin
report let me know what you think
comments yell at me ask me questions
whatever you want to do we accept all
except racist psychotic language and
homophobic slurs that's what the black
buttons for